[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday March
20th and I have begun watching the
office
[Music]
I like the office I am on team Pam I
haven't met Karen definitely
so far I'm a fan of Pam in fact maybe
too much of a fan as I've been watching
it with Kathryn and repeatedly telling
her how to fan I am of Pam but it's okay
right I mean I can think of four guys
right off the top of my head that
Kathryn has crushes on that she's never
met Eddie Izzard Christian Bale Edward
Martin Hugh Jackman you grant wait was
that five your little building excursion
got me thinking it was also my
experience with a punk-rock P beating
now a lot of people say that as you get
older you get smarter you mature you
start doing less stupid things and those
same people say that young people are
stupid but those people must never have
met your guide or Kurt the punk-rock
nerdfighter Kurt and the guide were
ready for experiences things may be a
little bit out of the ordinary maybe
even a little bit illegal the legal
experiences I do not condone when the
opportunity presents itself
why ignore something new something
interesting something different but I'm
proud of you for fighting your fear and
going ahead and chasing after that
experience I'm starting to very
seriously consider the prospect that as
you get older you get stupider
incrementally every year stupider and
stupider what I mean is that maybe you
have a bad experience or or you put your
values in all the wrong places and you
end up really consciously avoiding
anything that might be fun
I mean go to any Walmart in America and
watch what happens
the little kids put things on their
heads run around act silly do stupid
things and then their parents are like
Billy you can't do that in Walmart this
is just not the place for having fun you
know what I think we should all be at
Walmart putting stuff on our heads we
need to take a cue from the
four-year-olds of the world putting
things on your head is fun fun is good
for you there's no Walmart police force
telling you not to put things in your
head more than a dozen people completely
ignored me when I was sitting on the
street giving away peeps what I felt
like I was saying was here this is
something different something that
doesn't generally happen to you in your
normal
take this strangeness this experience
and have some fun with it
Kurt heard me loud and clear but that's
not what most of the people heard they
heard something like I'm weird and weird
people are dangerous if you find
yourself getting older and less silly do
something about it
put something on your head do it put it
on your hood I'll see you tomorrow